Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie. This will be my Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania.
Alternate ending deleted scenes,
alternate Post-Credits Scene Video.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There's going to be so much stuff
happening really soon.
Marvel started
talking about doing Ant-Man four.
Even in what's happening in Avengers
Kang Dynasty,
with all these different variants of Kang
from the Council of Kangs.
Of course I will do videos for everything
like the entire second Post-Credits scene
was meant to set up Loki Season two where
we'll see a bunch more Kang variants.
There's supposed to be six episodes
total of Loki Season two, just like Season
one, and Kang is supposed to appear
in about half of those.
They didn't say which episodes exactly,
but I'm assuming
he'll at least be in the last couple
of episodes.
Careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet,
because we have to talk about the end
and how they would have
originally changed it
with a bunch of this other footage,
including some of the really,
really weird variants of Kang.
Originally,
at the end of the movie, Ant-Man
and the Wasp would have gotten stuck
in the quantum realm.
They wouldn't made it back
through the portal
that Kang tried to make it
through himself, with Cassie Lang
being forced to find a way
to bring them back
like that was what they were setting up
with their whole beacon.
I could have found you in no time flat
if I'd had this years ago.
The special technology
she created using Hank
Pym journals and his help like Hank
Pym helped her build.
This was meant to be like a Hubble
telescope, but for the quantum realm.
So in addition to a couple other things,
she would have also on the side
have been searching for them
for the next couple of years
until Avengers Cane Dynasty,
because they were always
going to have Ant-Man
and the Wasp in Avengers Kang Dynasty.
One of the reasons why the writer said
that he changed this at the end
is because it felt so similar
to the events of the last movie.
Like there were a bunch of little kids
in the theaters, in the screenings
that were like, Wait a minute,
That's like the end of the last movie.
He got stuck in the quantum realm again.
Literally,
that's the only reason why they didn't
get stuck at the end of this movie.
Another deleted scene
would have had Cassie Lang
looking through
Hank Pym journals at the end of the movie,
a bit of an alternate post-credits scene
or an alternate
ending at the very end of the film
where she's continuing to look through
Hank Pym
journals and would have found a comic book
Easter Egg for the plan
to form the young Avengers.
And they would have called it
Avengers protocol in the comics.
That was Vision's plan
for forming a new Avengers team,
but they would have use this more
for young Avengers.
I think they'd originally intended
on teasing them
a little bit more in this movie,
and they just pulled some of that out
because the movie itself
was quite a bit shorter
than some of the other recent
Marvel Phase four movies.
Even though this is meant
to be a marvel Phase five movie.
There was a ton of stuff
that they deleted out of this movie,
like it was like a full 3 hours plus.
Then probably one of the biggest alternate
endings,
as they would have been less ambiguous
about Kang the Conqueror surviving
at the end of the movie, making it clear
that he would be a much bigger threat
to The Avengers and the Council of Kangs
in Avengers Kang Dynasty in Secret Wars.
I've talked about this
in my previous videos too.
At the end of the movie you just see him
get sucked into the multiverse engine,
but you don't see his body.
You don't actually see what happens to him
offscreen.
You see this big explosion and that's it.
Usually that's code
for he probably survived
because you didn't see a body, Otherwise
they would have shown you
everything happening on screen.
Like you would have seen his dead body
lying there
and they would have checked it like up.
Yep, definitely dead.
There was another alternate
ending with Bill Murray's cry LA.
He had a much bigger part in the end
of the movie helping them defeat Kang.
He would have also turned good again.
Like in the movie,
they imply that he used to be good
working with the freedom fighters.
He had this relationship
with Janet Van Dyne
over the past 30 years
that she'd been stuck there.
They mostly play that for comedy
and then imply after she escaped,
then Kang was able to turn him to the dark
side, so to speak, and he served him
at the end of the movie, Bill Murray's
character was supposed to turn good again,
helped the freedom fighters again
take down Kang,
and they would have been more ambiguous
about his ending
so that he could have come back
during Ant-Man four,
which Paul Rudd and the other characters
have talked about doing.
Also, they had scenes where Modok wound up
surviving the end of the movie
and will continue
to show up as a character in the MCU.
They could still do that,
but it has to be an alternate
version of Modok showing up.
It's not necessarily an alternate ending
because they didn't
film this in the movie.
But Michael Douglas was asked about
and for like, Are you coming back to do
more Ant-Man movies?
And he's like, Yeah, sure,
if they kill me,
if they did a fourth, would you come back
as long as I could die?
You may remember years ago
when they were back at Comic-Con
promoting the original Ant-Man movie,
I think it was the same time
they were promoting Avengers
Age of Ultron.
And he said some of the weirdest stuff,
like the most WTF stuff
coming out of his mouth.
They call that a Comic-Con virgin?
Yeah, I'm a Comic-Con virgin.
Don't shout from the chair.
Yeah, this is
a human being.
That's what it was. Yeah.
I'm popping my Comic-Con chair.
This is it.
We were also popping your cherry as well.
I'm sorry, but that's not enough cherries
is all right.
That's one of the funnier things
about having these older,
more established, more powerful stars.
They'll just say anything
that pops up in their mind,
no matter how messed up it is.
There have been rumors about them
killing off
Hank Pym during Avengers Kang Dynasty
like he'll be some big WTF death.
They're definitely going to kill off
a bunch of people in Kang Dynasty.
Then here's some more cool Easter eggs
for the Post-Credits scene
with the Council of Kangs.
Obviously there going to be another
big threat hanging to Loki Season two.
That'll be the next place that we see
them.
I'm not expecting to see any Kangs
during the secret Invasion series
because those episodes are coming before
Loki. Season two.
The whole Post-Credits scene
with the Victor timely variant of Kang
was meant to set up Loki Season two.
I've already been a much longer video
about that,
so I'll post links at the end of this
and down in the description below.
But generally
most of the different variants of Kang
that we see all over the place
in the Marvel movies,
the Marvel Disney Plus series,
the next couple of years
will be played by Jonathan Majors.
Like you'll visually be able
to see his face on screen.
With a few exceptions,
some of them look more like than others.
They said that
he actually put on 20 different costumes
when they were filming
this Post-Credits scene in the comics.
The number of main variants of carnage,
like the most powerful versions,
is much smaller.
That's why I say
the council is usually led
by the most powerful variants that we see,
like the Rama Tut Kang, Immortus,
the Scarlet Centurion in probably the Kang
the Conqueror variant that was exiled.
He was probably one of the four leaders
of the council
because at the end of Loki season one
and he remains Citadel,
there were four statues of the timekeepers
meant to represent
the four leaders of the Council of Kangs,
and one of them was broken.
That was the exiled Kang that we saw in
Amy and the Wasp Quantumania,
the he who remains variant of Kang
that was on the Council of Kang's,
which is another random Kang
that wound up winning the Kang
Multiverse war In the first version
of events at the first Multiverse War,
he killed the council
and got rid of all their timelines.
But then when Sylvie killed him,
it rebooted everything and it freed
all the other timelines to rise again
in the Council of Kangs rose up again.
So it wasn't like one of these different
Kangs turned into he who remains.
But you're talking about
some of the weirder Kang variants
and some cool Easter eggs and connections
across some of the recent Marvel movies.
They're calling this one Lizard Kang,
even though there's another one
that looks kind of like a reptile.
Right next to him here, Lizard
Kang isn't his name from the comics.
He's just meant to be a random Kang
from another universe,
from this particular comic book panel,
like he's based on this comic book panel.
But you can see that he's meant to
be like a lizard with a scaled skin,
and he's not played by Jonathan Majors.
Like this is another actor
underneath the makeup.
The cool connection
to the Spider-Man movies, particularly
Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man movies,
is that this Kang is meant to be from
a timeline where the Lizard in the Amazing
Spider-Man movies was successful
in evolving everyone into lizards.
They made a joke
about that during Spider-Man No Way Home
until the turn itself into a lizard.
Then he tried to turn the whole city
in the lizards.
It was crazy.
It wasn't crazy, Max.
It was the next step in human evolution.
You know, I can give you a real maker of.
Let me get into a lizard. Exactly.
In the Amazing Spider-Man
movies, the Lizards whole plan
was to evolve everyone into lizards.
The whole idea with Kangs
is that they're all born
as Nathaniel Richards in the 30th century.
So this Kang would have been born later
in a timeline where the lizard
was successful in this plan,
we knew we wanted to sort of
just give a tiny taste of the potential
of what some of these variants, these Kang
variants are and brief nods
to Rama, Todd, Centurion and Mortis.
Maybe not the prime versions,
maybe they're variants of those versions,
but just to sort of let Jonathan run
and have some fun, But always
my idea was let's,
let's end this thing with that
classic panel of the Council of Kangs
and do our version of that with
all these different Jonathan's.
We knew weirdly, like Rama Tut,
you know, just this sort of ancient
Egyptian version in the comics
was something that had potential.
But then we sort of bent it a little bit
and making this very strange sort
of bionic variant of the overall insight.
But we wanted to give three
distinct feelings and set up the idea
of now that Kang
the Conqueror has met the fate
he meets at the end of this movie,
what does it mean for the larger
sort of political body of Kang's right,
but sort of starting
to get into sort of the political aspect
of how the Kang's relate to each other,
which I think
holds really strong potential for Phase
five speaking of Andrew Garfield's Amazing
Spider-Man, Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man.
I just did a Venom
three video talking about Easter eggs
for those versions of Spider-Man.
We will see Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire come back for Secret Wars.
I don't know if they're going to be back
for Avengers Cain Dynasty Secret Wars
is more of a multiverse Avengers movie
where they pay off a lot of long running
Fox Marvel Easter eggs, Sony, Marvel,
Easter eggs like older classic movies.
So I do believe they have plans to
bring back a lot of those classic actors.
But most of that will be in Secret Wars.
Speaking of the Council of Kangs,
there was also report that Shang Xi, to
which they just put on the schedule.
I believe it'll come out sometime
before Secret Wars.
We're going to see a bunch
more Kang variants in that.
They didn't say which Kang variant
just a couple of Kang variants,
making it sound like Shang
Chi 2 will be a time travel based movie.
I'll do more videos about that.
When we get more details,
we'll learn more about Loki Season 2.
Way, Way.
Before that, we'll start
getting more trailers
in the next couple of months,
but most of their focus will be on teasing
Loki Season two
just because that's coming so soon.
If you've been reading the Kang Comics
in the last couple of years too,
they also did a storyline
that's relatively similar
to what they're doing in the MCU,
where you have a prime version of Kang
that eventually goes around
killing the Counsel of Kang's Lady Tree.
The Council of Kang's is a bunch of lesser
Kang variants in there
being a main Kang, which is kind of did
during Amy and the Wasp Quantumania
with this version of Kang
saying that he wanted to kill off
the rest of the Council.
That does make you wonder
if this Kang variant
is the one from the 616 Marvel Universe
because he remains said during Loki season
one that he wasn't the original Kang
from this main MCU timeline.
He was from another timeline
and just wound up
winning the Kang Multiverse War
and then made this timeline supreme.
We'll probably hear
about more deleted scenes
from the movie
in the next couple of months.
Sometimes it takes a little while
to find out about some of that stuff,
but reportedly there were a bunch
more scenes with the Freedom fighters
and they had a much bigger arc during
the movie with Cassie Lane's character.
If you have any big questions
or requests for bonus
videos,
just write them in the comments below.
Big reminder that Mandalorian Season
three episodes start next week too,
and I'll be doing videos
for all the episodes.
Everyone click here for that new Venom
three teaser and click here
for my Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
Post-Credits Scenes Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.